you two when you met did you really meet
him in a convenience store or is that a
lie no it it's a supermarket oh that's
kind of convenient it was convenient but
a convenient store is smaller that's
true it was conveniently located there's
convenient and then there super and was
he wearing a hockey jersey a Red Wings
Jersey I was a t-shirt it was what year
was this it's one of the rare days Rob
had a shirt on that's true put your
shirt on were you always shirtless I
don't I don't know what was wrong I I I
used to play with cuz I was so we used
to play in these small cot 100 degree
clubs so I end up just not wearing one
but looking back on that I'm like oh man
were you ever
shirtless yeah yeah there was walking
around shirtless in the summer days used
to write his Norton shirtless up
Beachwood Canyon just a pair of
sunglasses no helmet shirtless yeah that
was good those were the days Daring Do
yeah so you met and like you approached
him yeah and what' you say I said you
know where there's hockey
game and I was like it's 90 de out dude
there's no hockey here I wanted to play
some pickup hockey ice yeah man and he
didn't know oh I know no he didn't he
did know yeah where'd you go isoplex and
pck and Burbank Burbank and you brought
him there yeah every Tuesday and
Thursday Paul lag Gua had a pickup
game PA Canadian had a pickup game for
many many years many many years yeah
yeah do you still play no
because I think you play I was bummed
because it was like I think you played
in the the brookheimer league years ago
never played the Brooker game I was
playing in a couple I was on a couple of
teams during league play andu you play
goalie I was a go I was a goalie I am a
goalie you do you miss it yeah very much
would you ever do it again um yeah I
don't know how that would go but yeah
why not just rent the I knees man oh
yeah my knees my knees are bad I'm
almost 60 years old are you really are
you guys how old are you rob 78 okay
Brett Brett H 54 Brett's the baby he's
the baby we used to call him young Brett
domos K domrose that's what Kenny Funk
used to call him hey guys I'm doing
another live podcast downtown LA at the
Regent Theater and my special guest for
January 24th is Kristen Ritter Breaking
Bad Jessica Jones this is going to a
soldout event I know it it's going to be
exciting and uh there's a meet and greet
and so much fun that's going to happen
January 24th so make sure you get
tickets as soon as possible downtown Los
Angeles at the Regent inside of you with
Michael rosenbom with special guest
Kristen Ritter I'm so excited